425, das ist sicher
der hinterste Wagen.
Wo siehst du 425?
- Ich glaube es wirklich nicht.
(Englisch)
Um 7 Uhr?
Ist heute der 7., Jungs?
- Ja.
Ihr seid Pfeifen.
Ist nicht so schlimm.
Wir können ja mitfahren,
nur nicht in diesen Wagen.
Wir haben ein Interrail-Ticket.
- Aber für Nachtzüge ...
Man braucht eine Reservierung.
Wir fahren nach Mitternacht los
und kommen ...
Das ist doch ...
- Das ist wirklich nicht logisch.
Ich frage nach.
One, two, three, four.
Thank you.
Zugticket?
- Ja, wir holen es.
Es ist gut, wir haben eins bekommen.
Aber schreib den richtigen Tag hin!
Welchen soll ich?
- Den 8.
Nein, der 8. ist eben falsch.
Das Ticket zurück kostet.
Das sieht aus wie ein Tischtuch.
Das ist die Decke. Und
das kleinere musst du drauflegen.
Das grosse kannst du nehmen, um
dich zuzudecken, du grosser Junge.
Als Kopfkissen
nehme ich meinen Pullover.
Unterwegs mit Interrail.
So ein schönes Land.
- Das beste, in dem ich je war.
Ein Liebespaar ...
- Das ist Freiheit.
... vier beste Kumpels ...
Ich freue mich auch.
Dann ist immer jemand da.
What the heck?
... und zwei Freundinnen ...
Erst wenn wir weg sind, sagen wir
unseren Eltern, dass wir hier waren.
... reisen einen Monat lang mit
dem Zug von Abenteuer zu Abenteuer.
* Temporeiche elektronische Musik *
Hey, Maya.
- Hallo.
Und, vermisst ihr euer Bett?
Oder uns?
- Hm ...
Nein?
- Mich?
Das Bett nicht, aber euch schon.
Ah, okay.
Jö.
Das Bett ist voll easy.
- Ich vermisse dich auch, Maya.
Oh!
We miss you.
* Maya lacht. *
Ja, es ist ruhig zu Hause.
Eben ...
- Bist du nicht pleite?
Was?
- Bist du noch nicht pleite?
Ich bin gar nicht pleite.
Wir geben nicht viel Geld aus.
Wir sparen Geld mit Couchsurfing.
- Stimmt.
Was kostet denn Couchsurfing?
- Null.
Null?
Was?
- Really.
Man bezahlt nichts.
- Wow!
Wieso bietet jemand so etwas an?
Weil er offen für neue Leute ist,
weil es ihm zu Hause langweilig ist
oder weil er für Backpacker eine
billige Alternative bieten will.
Okay.
- Das ist mega nett.
Nice.
Nachdem der Campingplatz in Slowenien
eher eine Enttäuschung war,
sind Deborah und Arthur
wieder auf der Suche
nach Natur und echter Wildnis.
Ich werde müde werden auf der Fahrt,
ich kann nicht wach bleiben.
Ist gut, ich passe auf.
Auf unsere Sachen?
Wobei ...
- Ich habe den speziellen Griff.
Schau!
Nice.
- Das kann nicht geklaut werden.
Zieh mal daran!
Ich stelle mir vor, ich wäre so ein
1,90 m grosser, 180 kg schwerer ...
Du musst erst mal hier durchkommen.
... mit Wodkagestank,
Zigarettengeruch,
einer Adidasjacke und einer Glatze
und Gesichtstattoos.
Ich steige aus und habe gesehen, wie
du deinen Pass da reingetan hast -
oder auch nicht, aber ich bin
ein Psycho und will deine Tasche.
Ich reisse, du brichst dir
den Finger und das Handgelenk.
Mach doch!
Du schaffst es nicht. Das ist fest.
Okay.
Ja, es ist schon in Ordnung.
Das ist der Debbie-Griff.
Gut gemacht.
Die Debbie-Wickelung.
Im Zug zu zeichnen, ist schwierig.
So.
Aber einfach noch mehr,
damit man es besser sieht.
Oder einfach ... Es ist okay.
Nicht schlecht.
Stell dir vor, es wäre hier.
Es schaut ein bisschen raus,
wenn ich nichts mache,
aber wenn ich mich bewege ...
Das wäre doch nice.
I like it.
Die vier Freunde sind unterwegs
nach Kosice im Osten der Slowakei.
Luc darf nicht zuvorderst gehen,
der hat die längsten Beine.
Dem sei so.
Für Luc ist Kosice
die letzte Station seiner Reise.
Er muss wegen eines Familienfestes
in die Schweiz zurück.
Bist du sicher?
Er sagte,
wir sollen einfach klingeln.
Hm?
Da kommt jemand.
Huh, was wird das noch?
Ah, schau mal: Hostel Kosice.
Hello, nice to meet you.
Hi.
Jetzt bin ich aber gespannt.
Nach elf Tagen on the road
suchen die Jungs einen Ort,
wo sie Wäsche waschen können.
Ich wollte hier was suchen.
Dort vorne?
- Das ist es nicht.
Der dort vorne verkauft Parkett.
Und Böden.
- PVC.
Das hier ist eine Beiz.
Das ist ein Feuerwerkladen.
Ähm ...
Und hier ist das Silvia Studio -
das ist wohl nicht der Waschsalon.
Nein.
Es soll ein Shell-Dings sein.
Shell,
ist das nicht eine Tankstelle?
Doch,
aber dort kann man auch waschen.
Ach so.
Elias, wie heisst der Laden?
Sicher nicht.
- Doch!
Das ist das Erste,
was ich gefunden habe.
Egal.
Wir sind 4 km
zu einer Toilette gelaufen.
Du bist so eine Pfeife!
Deshalb frage ich ja. Shell ist
eine Tankstelle. Ich weiss nicht ...
Aber ...
Nein, Elias.
Jetzt ist Schluss.
- Nächstes Mal suche ich selbst.
Also.
- Also.
Also ...
Wieso gehen wir nicht zu diesem?
Ja, wir können zu dem. Wo ist er?
Hast du jemals schon
etwas im Internet gesucht?
Schön,
dass man dich mal lachen sieht.
Wie kannst du das
noch lustig finden?
Ach komm!
Die Reise ist doch auch
ein Test für die vier Freunde.
* Pfiff *
Hast du es gefunden?
Ja.
Weisst du, was nebenan ist?
Ein Feuerwerkladen.
Das sieht genau so aus.
- Hello.
(Frau) Hello.
- Hello. - Hello.
Hi.
Perfect, thank you.
- You're welcome.
Celeste.
- Wo ist es?
Lili finde ich auch schön.
Camille.
Celeste kenne ich auch.
Liane.
Oh mein Gott, ich liebe Liane.
Also, für Mädchen habe ich:
Dara, Divia, Viola, Davina.
Emilia, Fabia, Fabiola ...
- Das sind alles italienische Namen.
Eben.
Serena, Angelica, Selene ...
Angelica wäre italienisch
oder deutsch ausgesprochen?
Italienisch.
No offense gegen Lars,
ich liebe ihn über alles,
aber sein Nachname ist einfach
der basicste Name der Schweiz.
Mega basic.
- Der basicste Name der Schweiz.
Sorry, das würde
den ganzen Namen versauen.
Stell dir vor: Celeste ...
... Müller!
Keine Ahnung, es ist ...
- Er ist einfach basic.
Ich denke,
es ist besser für das Kind,
wenn die Eltern
den gleichen Nachnamen haben.
Oder wenn man so heisst
wie beide Eltern.
(Durchsage) Notre TER desservira
la gare Des Arcs - Draguignan.
Avant de descendre, veillez
a ne rien d'oublier a votre place.
Je vous rapelle
que pour votre securite
d'attendre l'arret complet du train.
Du würdest also heiraten wollen?
J...
Aber du bist dir nicht sicher?
- Nein.
Wieso?
Es ist sicher etwas Tolles
und etwas,
das ein Paar noch stärker verbindet.
Aber es bindet auch so richtig.
Man holt das Gesetz dazu.
Weisst du ...
Notre train arrivera
en gare de Carnoules.
Prochain arret Carnoules.
Er hat mir vor Kurzem gesagt,
ich sei die Richtige.
Jö!
- Ich so: "Oh mein Gott."
Ich denke schon, dass wir
beide hoffen, dass es hält.
Sonst wäre ich diese Beziehung
nicht eingegangen.
What the fuck?
Wie heisst die Haltestelle?
- Perpignan.
Das stand dort!
Ich dachte noch,
auf der App stimme es.
Aber wieso sagtest du,
wir sollen hier aussteigen?
Whatever.
- Du sagtest, wir sollen hier raus.
Ja, es stand dort Perpignan.
Hier sind wir voll im Wohnquartier.
Ja, voll.
Aber das ist local, das ist wenig-
stens weit weg von den Touristen.
Es ist ein cooles Gefühl,
wenn man im Geschäft nicht direkt
auf Englisch angesprochen wird.
Oh shit, der Bus ist geflashed.
- Der Bus ist geil.
Der ist voll classy.
Die Vordertür ist einfach offen.
Das ist der Bill-Clinton-Boulevard?
Und eine fette Amerikaflagge.
Oho!
- Ja.
Die Autos sehen geil aus.
- Die sind echt nice.
Weisst du, woran mich das erinnert?
In Amerika gibt es doch
diese Bilder von Autos,
die verlassen in der Wüste stehen.
Ich muss sie fotografieren.
Ich weiss gar nicht, wie.
Das ist ...
Ich mache das morgen.
Oder warte, doch!
Schnell!
Noch mit dem Licht des Autos.
Ist es cool geworden?
- Yes.
Es ist sogar richtig cool geworden.
- Achtung, Auto.
Zeig mal!
Wow.
- Nicht wahr?
Ja, das ist special, echt.
- Mhm.
Was soll ich jetzt machen?
Mann, es schnurrt ganz fest.
Wie kann das nicht aufwachen?
Es ist schon lange wach,
es weigert sich einfach aufzustehen.
Nein.
Bring es an einen warmen Ort,
schnell!
Es tut mir leid, mein Katzenfreund.
Nach ziellosem Umherirren
will unser Paar
sein Glück in Albanien versuchen.
* Beschwingte Balkanmusik *
Wow.
(Maya) Hä?
What the hell?
(Durchsage) Barcelona Sants.
R... R1.
Hier ist keine R1.
Oh Gott, nein.
Nein.
What the heck? Ist das eine Küche?
- Ich glaube schon.
Die Küche. Also Wannabe-Küche.
Es gibt nicht mal einen Kühlschrank.
Das war's dann mit Kochen.
Wird wohl nichts.
Wie ist das WC?
Ich muss aufs WC.
WC - draussen.
Waschmaschine auch.
Hier klemmt etwas.
* Prusten *
Sollen wir im Schlafsack schlafen?
Wäre das hygienischer?
- Können wir machen.
* Wasser sprudelt. *
Was zum Teufel?
Der Boden löst sich auf.
Erst wenn wir weg sind, sagen wir
unseren Eltern, dass wir hier waren.
Erst wenn es uns gut geht.
- Ja.
Sie müssen es noch nicht wissen.
Sie würden sich
unnötig Sorgen machen.
Wow.
Let's do it.
Denkst du, es wird gut aussehen,
so dick?
I don't know.
Für Maya ist es das erste Tattoo.
Ihre Mutter hat keine Ahnung, dass
sie sich ein Tattoo stechen lässt.
Oh!
- That's why.
Smart.
* Sanfte Celloklänge *
Zeig die Flower Power!
Deborah und Arthur sind zufällig
mit einem Einheimischen
ins Gespräch gekommen.
(Englisch)
Kann er sie in die Wildnis bringen?
Wow.
- Wow.
Ich fühle mich
echt langsam schuldig.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich müsse etwas zurückgeben.
Wie haben wir das verdient?
- Nicht wahr?
Stell dir vor in der Schweiz,
der würde nie ...
Nein, der Bauer
würde dich wegschicken.
"Mein Land!"
- "Wir machen keine Privatfahrten!"
* Pulsierende Musik *
(Albanisch)
Die nächste Reise
geht wieder nach Albanien.
Wirklich.
- Egal wann, wir kommen wieder.
So ein schönes Land.
- Ja.
Ganz coole Leute.
- Unglaublich.
Das beste Land, in dem ich je war.
As pure as it gets.
Du siehst aus wie aus einer Wasser-
werbung, die ich mal gesehen habe.
Nicht auf dem Campingplatz oder so,
man geht einfach mal los
und schaut, was das Leben so bringt.
Das ist Freiheit.
Es ist Lucs letzter Abend.
Morgen muss er nach Bern zurück.
Wir gehen etwas trinken,
dann sehen wir uns in zwei Wochen
wieder und gehen etwas trinken.
Es ist nicht dasselbe.
Ja, aber es ist kein ...
- ... Weltuntergang.
Ja.
- Ein bisschen schon.
Nein.
Aber wenn du ...
Wenn du mich so traurig
sehen willst, dann ...
Du bist so schräg.
Gehen wir!
Luc, komm!
Wir gehen.
Nein.
Nein, ich komme nicht mit.
- Wieso?
Erstens, weil mir schlecht ist.
Zweitens
werde ich sowieso nichts trinken.
Drittens werde ich
keinen Sonnenaufgang anschauen.
Und viertens,
wenn wir trinken und reden wollen,
können wir es auch hier tun.
Also los, gehen wir.
Wer hat den Schlüssel?
- Ich habe ihn.
Oh shit, was?
- Nicht schlecht, wie?
Ja.
- Das Zweisekundenzelt.
* Grillenzirpen *
Nein, es geht nicht.
Au! Verfickte Scheisse, verdammt!
Schauen, dass es
von allen Seiten gleich bleibt.
Shit.
Sind sie weg?
Ich muss immer noch aufs WC.
Die wohnen hier,
die gehen nicht weg.
Vielleicht
sind sie kurz rausgegangen.
Ich will nicht auf den Boden stehen
ohne Flipflops.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Die Frage ist:
Werden wir etwas anderes finden?
Nehmen wir jetzt schon alles mit?
Oder lassen wir es hier?
Ich sage, wir nehmen alles mit.
Und dann
schliessen wir es irgendwo ein.
* Ein Mann ruft etwas. *
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass wir nicht so heikel sind.
Es sei denn, es geht um Kakerlaken.
Oh my gosh.
Ich muss auch aufs WC,
aber ich traue mich nicht.
Hoi, Papi.
Gut.
Wir sind ... Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Wir machen einfach noch Pläne
hier im Airbnb.
* Zwei Männer
reden laut vor dem Zimmer. *
Ja, wir haben
viele Bekanntschaften gemacht.
Äh ...
... in den Hostels
und auch hier im Airbnb
und beim Couchsurfen.
Ja, viele nette Leute,
aber die hier sind etwas komisch.
Einfach komische Typen.
Nein, es ist schon ... Keine Ahnung,
ich bin mega froh, hier zu sein.
Aber es wäre cool,
euch auch hier zu haben.
Ab und zu.
What the fuck?
Ich frage mich,
ob ich hier duschen soll.
Ich dusche hier nicht.
Ich kann nicht
vier Tage ohne Duschen sein.
Ich weiss nicht.
Ich dusche hier nicht.
Gehen wir?
- Ja.
Lucs Zug nach Hause
fährt erst später.
David, Elias und Luca reisen
weitere zwei Wochen durch Osteuropa.
Ich mache so, denn Luc
hat seine Bettdecke gelüftet.
Warte!
Mein Duvet.
Tipptopp.
- Nein, noch mal.
Mach noch eins.
Schön.
- Wunderprächtig.
Hey.
- Tschüss. Gute Reise.
Pass auf die Wohnung auf.
Komm gut nach Hause.
Tschüss, bleib sauber!
Du auch. Bis bald.
Zieh gut um.
Danke.
- Schick uns ein Foto.
Klar.
Elias, bis zum nächsten Mal.
- Komm gut nach Hause.
Passt auf euch auf!
- Keine Sorge.
Tschüss.
* Lachen *
Tschau.
Deborah und Arthur
haben draussen übernachtet
und sich entschieden, das Zelt als
Lager für ihre Sachen zu benutzen.
God damn it.
Oh, hey.
- Hey.
Was machst du denn hier?
- Sauber.
Ein halber Krebs.
Ja, v.a. ist es krass, wie gross
die werden - für Süsswasserkrebse.
Überraschend gross.
Daraus könnte man
einen Löffel basteln,
wenn man das putzen würde.
Nicht?
Wenn man das putzen würde
und hier einen Stock
durchziehen würde ...
Es ist etwas abartig.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
wenn das Feuer dort hinkommt,
wird es wieder matschig.
Nein, das sollte brennen.
Brennen?
- Also trocknen.
Sicher?
- Ja.
Nicht oben verstreichen, denn
du setzt oben wieder mehr drauf.
Ich würde
von unten nach oben streichen.
Mit beiden Händen,
dann kannst du die Luft rauspressen.
Okay.
Mhm.
Wait a second.
Mit meinen letzten 2 % oder so
will ich noch ein Bild machen.
Der ist hässlich.
- Oben finde ich ihn voll schön.
Der sieht aus wie ein alter Opi.
- Das ist das Geile.
Voller Runzeln.
Ich freue mich auf den Burrito.
Ich freue mich aufs Hinsetzen.
- Oh.
Soll ich den Rucksack nehmen?
Are you sure?
- Ja, voll.
Sonst sagst du es einfach.
Die Freundinnen sind einmal mehr
auf der Suche nach veganem Essen.
Die lassen das Fleisch
aus Argentinien einfliegen.
Wow. Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Ich schätze, wir haben eine Wahl.
Aber es ist okay,
ich habe Lust auf Pizza.
Wir müssen es gemeinsam probieren.
Ich hätte einfach reingebissen,
ohne zu schneiden.
Cheers.
- Prost.
* Sanfte Gitarrenmusik *
Ah, es kocht tatsächlich.
Nice, dann filtere ich es
und fülle es ab.
Okay, das ist safe.
Und wir können ja 5 Min. warten.
Perfekt bemessen.
Nice.
Es schwimmen ein paar Sachen drin.
Ist das immer so?
- Ja.
Okay.
Yeah, eine Flasche.
Soll ich mal probieren?
Ich probiere es mal.
Es ist wahrscheinlich
noch sehr warm.
Mmh, sehr gut.
* Lautes Grillenzirpen *
Ich werde diesen Löffel
heute fertig kriegen.
Heute werde ich damit essen.
Sonst hast du keinen.
- Das ist mein Tagesziel.
Was ist dein Tagesziel?
Die Frage ist:
Wieso ist Luc nicht mitgekommen?
Ich glaube, es ging mehr darum:
"Wenn ihr einfach hierbleibt und
sauft, bleibe ich noch etwas wach."
Ich glaube, das war seine Message.
Ich verstehe es, wenn Luc ein paar
mal keine Lust hatte, auszugehen.
Das ist seine Entscheidung.
Deswegen mögen wir ihn
nicht mehr oder weniger.
Es ist ...
Wir sind uns das von Luc
in dieser Intensität nicht gewohnt.
Und ...
Wir wissen auch nicht konkret,
warum.
Aber, eben ...
Ich glaube, er weiss,
wenn er mit uns über etwas
reden will, kann er das tun -
und wenn nicht, dann nicht.
Luc ist jemand,
der gerne seine eigene Pace hat
und ...
Wenn ihm irgendetwas zu viel wird,
will er sich etwas zurückziehen
und einfach mal abschalten.
Und vielleicht war das ein wenig ...
Wir waren auch
zwei Wochen ständig zusammen.
Ja, voll.
Wie geht es dir?
Hast du dich verletzt?
Entschuldigung.
- Du musst dich nicht entschuldigen.
Das ist so peinlich.
Du wirst diese Leute
nie wieder sehen. Sie waren nett.
Es ist mir peinlich vor dir.
- Wieso.
Ich will,
dass du eine schöne Zeit hast.
Hä? Das habe ich doch.
Ich bin mega schnell
wieder aufgewacht.
Ich habe dich geschlagen.
Hast du das gemerkt?
Hast du es nicht gemerkt?
Warst du bewusstlos?
Ich habe nichts gemerkt.
Also so.
Ja, das habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Aber ich weiss, dass es nützt. Bei
mir musste man es auch schon machen.
Im Nachtzug nach Lissabon
lernen die beiden Freundinnen
eine allein reisende Amerikanerin
kennen.
In der nächsten Folge werden
die Jungs aus einem Club geworfen.
Oh mein Gott,
ich hatte solches Glück.
Ich will nicht deinetwegen
in eine Schlägerei geraten, David.
Deborah und Arthur arbeiten
in Griechenland in einem Ökodorf.
In Portugal erfährt Francesca
endlich ihr Prüfungsresultat.
Muriel hat auch bestanden.
Ich schreibe meiner Nachbarin.
Hat sie geschrieben?
- Sie ist online!